now a former royal marine says that he
has been let down by the government as
he remains stranded in kabul he says one
of his staff members who is pregnant was
evacuated and is now stuck in terrible
conditions in germany
uh let us bring in uh paul or penn uh
farving uh from kabul penn good to see
you this morning and clearly the
situation uh at your end will be
concerning uh you allege that there was
a a flight that was blocked by the
ministry of defense coming to rescue you
rescue your staff rescue your animals i
just want to play you the response that
the defense secretary gave to me just a
little bit earlier in the program and
and then we'll get you to respond just
have a listen to what mr wallace had to
say
penn farthing is a british possible
holder and has done an amazing thing in
kabul he he was offered a flight out i
think last friday or certainly he was
called forward to the airport for
processing his own wife i think left
about the same time
and exited the country and that is our
strong advice to him is to
leave the country um no one is blocking
the charter flight that people have
raised money
other than the fact it this is not about
flights on the ground
and whether or not uh penn can get on
the flight this is simply not about you
know if that aircraft flew in today it
would probably sit there it would block
the airfield it would sit there empty
because it's about getting as i said
earlier the flow
through
the gate through the barriers and into
the airport and onto the aircraft
uh pen the argument from from mr wallace
who carry went on to say i'm not
prepared to prioritize pets over people
it's not a question about getting the
flight in it's a question of getting
people to the airport your response
mr wallace
um i never asked you to prioritize pets
over people at no point have i ever said
that
whatsoever
and
we've got a flight and we've said we
will wait
you've just got to give us this call
sign so we can actually get it in play
we can get the um airline to actually
start the flight plans and then we will
sit quite happily and wait
we've got an aircraft that we need to
put 69 people on it's got capacity for
250 people
and in that cargo hold you'll be empty i
can't pop people in the cargo hold but i
can park
my animals in that cargo hold little
animals like ewok
and there's going to be absolutely no
commitment from the british military to
help me do that i just need this isaf
bullseye number and also i'd like to
point out that whilst the prime minister
has actually given and said that our
staff have been granted their
visas to travel to england i've got
absolutely no confirmation i've got
nothing in writing so if i get stopped
at a taliban checkpoint with them
they'll get turned around
and he absolutely knows mr wallace that
i said i'm not leaving here without my
staff
so i'm not going to go to the airport
and just go on an airplane so that his
problem goes away that's not going to
happen
i served my country for 22 years and the
mod has cancelled my emergency line that
i had so that i could get updates on the
situation and let them know updates he
has abandoned me here in afghanistan and
wants me to go quiet not going to happen
mr wallace not on my watch you're
dealing with the wrong person pen sorry
to interrupt pen but i just i just want
to kind of reiterate the point that the
defense secretary is waking that it's
not about seats on planes or the the
availability of those it is about the
crush that is taking place outside the
airport and the inability that are
thousands of people already waiting
there and the inability of people to to
get through to get to the airport that
if your plane did arrive there would be
no way of guaranteeing that anyone would
be able to get on it
getting into the airport the british
government can't help me with it that's
my problem
i'll be in the airport and i shall be
there with my staff and with my animals
and if he doesn't allow me to get on
that aircraft then i will have to park
all of my dogs and cancer sleep on the
runway
so i'm going to get into that airport
so he can't what's he going to tell me
not to now
he's just told me to get to the airport
and i'm taking my staff from animals
with me
um it's that simple
i'm not being dictated to
by an mp just because he actually has
completely failed this operation to get
people off the ground we are going to
end up leaving people behind
this whole thing is absolutely just a
disaster
so i'm getting to that airport and i
shall be in there with my people my
staff and the animals and we've got a
flight we need a nice half call sign if
he doesn't bring that to us then he'll
be leaving us at that airport um i'm
absolutely disgusted with him i can't
believe
i can't believe he just said that just
no he's picked on the wrong person i'm
not backing down
no way never
we're about to run out of time but i
just want to squeeze in one final
question again the point that the
defense secretary makes is look air
space
needs to be prioritized air traffic
control and and the number of the number
of planes on the ground need to be
controlled
you can't simply just fly into kabul
international airport these days given
the security situation outside the
cordon he does want to get you and your
stuff sorry go on yeah hang on hang on
there are there are charter flights
arriving into that airport
there are charter flights arriving into
this airport
if america can do it why can't britain
i'm not taking these excuses
absolutely not and i've just seen images
of a car being flown out of afghanistan
if that's true
they're rescuing cars you've got to be
joking me
sorry no
i'm not backing down he's picked on the
wrong person it's not going to happen
i'll be in that airport with my staff
and with my animals i need my flight to
be able to land with other
people chartered aircraft in then so can
we um penn we do hope that you and your
staff stay very well indeed very well
very safe uh hopefully we'll speak again
soon uh take care and thanks for joining
us all right thank you appreciate that
thank you